[Music]  a local attorney accused of sexually of  sexual harassing his employees at his  office appeared in court today  prosecutors also revealed more about  douglas crawford's actions in his office  alleging that he was offering legal  services to clients in exchange for  sexual acts  any of these acts are caught on video as  his entire office is under surveillance  it was so well known that the  staffers would sometimes go gather  around the  video monitoring  the video monitors in order to watch him  have sex with clients when his door was  closed  crawford had been practicing law here in  las vegas for more than three decades  his bail was set at a hundred thousand  dollars and he's due back in court in  july